hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I am your host
Mark Ellis Jacqueline Coley out
somewhere in the world on assignment
perhaps she's covering the canned film
festival or maybe she found the all
spark for the Autobots that's a
reference to last week's episode where
we covered Transformers Revenge of the
Fallen with two wonderful guests so
wonderful we invited them back here for
the following week Danny Fernandez and
Mark Bernard and you're both great
writers great podcasters Danny you're a
great actor uh you guys do all the
things all the time including currently
uh out there on the picket lines
supporting the wga so welcome back to
the show how are things going out there
in the world uh my Tan's getting great
my hair does change color I want people
to know and I have natural highlights
from it being from the Sun I actually
have been very protective
I don't know if enough white people out
there protecting their skin as much as
they on behalf of all white people and
again I was just in Mexico
um we are not no just walking around
there like pink salmon like we just like
we're just so dumb that and and it's me
leading the charge because what I'll do
is I'll take a little bit of sunscreen
and then I'll I have like my my what I
know my proper spots are so white people
usually forget about the earlobes but
first thing first thing I'm coding with
the sunscreen is I go earlobes I'll go
uh all over my face and then I always
have like a random clavicle that I
forget that turns pink and then the back
of the neck is another one that's like
that's a prime spot so basically what
the science is telling us now is if you
are a lighter person you just need to
walk outside and have sunscreen all over
your body at all at all times you know
and if you were a darker person it
couldn't hurt like yeah I I have been
recommending to the people of color that
I see it's like hey don't forget it
don't forget it I know we've often
forgot it myself included but we're
gonna be out there every day for four
hours a day in the sun in Southern
California like let's take care of
ourselves yeah this this was when I was
at in Mexico the lifeguards uh who
worked there they had like full body
suits that they wore it because they're
out there in the Sun every day and so
they got to be super hot but it's
literally like a wetsuit as opposed to
like the lifeguards at the pool where I
was growing up where it's just a like a
skimpy bikini or just like some board
shorts and just twirl on the whistle
like no they're head to toe covered
it's not Baywatch it's not even the
king's Mill Pool back in Williamsburg
Virginia it's just uh Zig felt Follies
full suit
and you know something about the sun
because you grew up in Texas primarily
right yeah I mean also my family is also
from Southern California as well so I've
always been always been in the Sun never
not been in the sun yeah it's uh I mean
I love the sun I love vitamin D Ward
knows Molly the Wonder Dog loves it yeah
I think the dog is like solar powered
because no they know they need Vitamin D
right right but she'll wake up now she
wakes up at like 11 30 noon and uh she
literally is 16. she's a 16 year old she
sleeps in and then you get you get you
get her going she's kind of like a
diesel engine takes a minute to warm her
up and then she just once she gets in
the sun she's just like ah she's bathing
at it but she's absorbing the power of
the sun much like what the Decepticons
were trying to harvest in Transformers
Revenge of the Fallen which is Oscar
nominated as Danny wanted to point out
and then by Night Time Molly's just
running all over the place because she's
got all that solar energy inside of her
I can't believe that you TR you did that
transition
the Transformers run to the phone
because as of tomorrow rise of the Beast
is out in theaters and and Marcus you
brought up on the show last week like
every one of these Transformers trailers
just looks so awesome it's like they
finally got it turned around bumblebee
did actually turn it around 91 of the
Tomato Meter so hopefully rise of the
Beast
um and just to get your clear-cut
opinion on this Danny do we think rise
of the Beast has what it takes to be the
second fresh Transformers movie
I gotta go I know Mark brought up that
it has Anthony Ramos I think he's so
beloved it's gonna be hard to not love
this film and he's such a more grounded
kind of lead character than what shiawa
both was and like part of that was just
the the Michael Bay Direction but and
and in Revenge of the Fallen when he's
doing all the Beautiful Mind stuff he's
just he's so manic all the time which I
think worked for like his character in
Disturbia early on in his career stuff
like that but yeah Anthony Ramos is just
like a guy everybody can root for and
like what Haley Steinfeld was in
bumblebee so I I'm excited about this
movie The More I start thinking about
the trailer I'm like yeah we could get a
really good film but trailers have lied
to us before particularly in this
franchise that's their job
to convince you of a thing that may or
may not be true
I mean for you I mean I know you guys
are
extended files but you also have uh busy
schedules uh with your various things
and now you add a strike to the whole
thing so you don't have a lot of time
just to get out there and see a flick is
there a movie that you circled on your
calendar coming out later this Summer
that you say I need to be there opening
night uh yeah yeah the minute I saw the
first trailer for this movie I was in
the minute I knew this movie was coming
I was in the back
um Mission Impossible dead reckon okay
Is My Jam because Tom Cruise is the
closest we have to Jackie Chan in that
here's a man who will probably kill
himself for my fifteen dollars put his
life on the line throw himself off a
thing he will jump off a thing he will
run for as far as a man has ever run
before yes he will all for my the price
of admission and I appreciate that
dedication to earning my money I think
our our expert researcher Mark Hoffmeyer
I want to say that he clocked all the
times that that Tom Cruise ran or or
this might have been from another
article I want to make sure I give
credit where credit's due I think Tom
Cruise total on-screen running has
cleared like six miles like in all of
his movies put them together I think
he's done over over six miles I mean in
in Mission possible three they tell him
how far he's got a room like that's
that's the first really great one it's
like oh it's it's Simon Pegg but look at
the map he's gonna run like a mile and a
half to get there and it's like all
right Evan off the hands go and he's
pumping and it's a solid cut of just
watching him running Shanghai across
like yeah all of that all the time yeah
and that became like the fetish of these
movies it's like make him run make him
run make him look crazy stunts uh dead
reckoning on your list Danny I feel that
he has more certifications than any
other actor because he can like fly he
had no I mean like I mean like pilot I
think he does have he has so many he got
some for Top Gun right and like I'm sure
the Days of Thunder got him some like he
can like yeah truck and like a
motorcycle and uh you have to have
different certifications and licenses
for those sure well I know he wanted to
go even farther with top gun Maverick
because like he was flying I think he
was flying like a hornet or like an F-14
I want to say
um the the plane in the movie is an F-18
that's the character in the movie but he
ever I think they like repeatedly
applied to the Navy whoever's in charge
of the Navy Tom Cruise kept the lobby
and like hey can I please please please
fly an F-18 and they're like dude we're
not letting you fly an F-18 you know how
he would get it he should just join
what else does he have that's his final
task in life he could just join the Navy
and then he could get he could work his
way up the ladder then I I that would be
such a great if we could film that if we
could make that documentary series I 100
believe he would do that yeah if you
pitch that to him it's like listen man
you're too old for this I know you don't
want to hear it you're like 68 years old
nobody's gonna ensure you to do this the
only thing left for you to do is enlist
be the oldest rookie I hope his eyes are
good gotta have good eyes
there used to be a show on Discovery
Channel and it was like buds training
which is what the Navy Seals go through
and it was just so compelling because of
the incredible athleticism like the
grueling things that they have to
perform and pull off in order to become
a Navy SEAL and the way that you quit
there's like an actual way that you quit
buds training because so many people
watch out is you take your helmet and
you wake up in the morning and when
you're done you take your helmet and you
just put it next to the previous helmet
and you just go back to wherever you
were going to be doing in the Navy
because it's that damn tough and from
the first episode to the last episode
every season it's like no helmets and a
slew of helmets just because it is so
damn tough Tom Cruise maybe that one guy
that could pull it off yeah yeah all
right so Mission Impossible maybe not
the highest on Danny's uh movie watching
counter this summer what is the movie
that you said oh I gotta see this I'm
really excited for the blackening so I
know Dwayne Perkins uh who's in it that
also is premiering or maybe by the time
this came out premiered at Tiff
um indeed that I believe got picked up
by Lionsgate so I'm really excited all
black cast and I think they're on the
poster it says we can't all die first
I'm just so excited one horror you know
is my jam I think it's such a great way
both of our short films are horror
Thrillers all right so you guys have
short films I wanted to mention too
Danny yours is in the static and it's
premiering it while we've uh it might
have already premiered as of this right
yes and uh Mark you're short it's called
Splinter and I think if this is mid-june
then I will be on my way to the
Chattanooga film festival in Tennessee
which is apparently phenomenal like I've
heard nothing but good things because at
first I got the Chattanooga okay my
producer's like you have to submit to
Chattanooga and I'm super excited to go
anywhere I overlooked Festival which is
a horror film festival um we played the
uh the pan-african film festival we'll
be showing it at Comic-Con this year
very exciting oh what day of Comic Con
uh probably Thursday it's looking that's
awesome yeah okay very exciting good
good for you yes I love horror I love
POC made horror films as well and so
that I'm really I'm really excited and
Tim story directed from the barbecue yes
yeah uh what were y'all's like horror
influences growing up because you're you
I know that even before you were horror
filmmakers you had like this love of the
genre so Danny when you're growing up
you you got San Diego Texas we already
mentioned you grew up in these nice
sunshiny States what was it about like
the horror genre that spoke to and what
horror properties shows movies novels
were you like oh this is what I'm
honestly horror loves Texas obviously
there's Texas Chainsaw Massacre
it does and then you have stuff like and
then you have stuff like The Hills Have
Eyes which is my family would go on road
trips and you're in those those areas
where there's like nobody you know out
there where it's just kind of you at any
moment you could be taken advantage of
nobody you can see nobody that you can
see definitely stopped at gas stations
that were that were similar to that we
don't get many visitors this way no more
exactly your kids going camping there's
many areas that are still like that
um I will I loved Halloween we'll always
love Halloween I just have so much
respect for for the original Halloween
love that I know Mark and I also grew up
on the Twilight Zone heavy influenced
and as much as that is sci-fi it also is
a try not to cuss here a ton of horror
um in it with episodes like The Masks uh
frightening accuracy in uh the Twilight
Zone too foretelling and uh ahead of its
time in many ways such a progressive
show that I don't think a lot of people
gave it credit for because they just
thought they were watching sci-fi horror
and there's a whole lot of social
commentary Rod Sterling had in there too
with a real Martian please stand up it's
all about sort of McCarthyism and you
know I have the beholder is just
frightening frightening you know global
warming climate change all that stuff is
in there you're so good every time we're
on a plane we still look at the wing
just to make sure there's a man on the
wing he's gotten it in he's gotten it in
your head yeah that was also a
terrifying is this man having a
psychotic William Shatner is this man
having a psychotic breakdown or is he
actually seeing a gremlin yeah Mark what
were your uh your early influences
um I remember the first one that really
scared the parents off me was The
Exorcist because I didn't believe that a
movie that was as old as I was
um right any effect made in 1971 how
scary could this be and it terrified I
was similarly way too cocky going into
my first official feeling of The
Exorcist it was on TV when when we were
living in Northern California and me and
my brother and sister we were too young
to get it so all we saw was this girl in
bed throwing up and cussing and we
thought it was awesome we thought it was
hilarious like yeah she's giving it to
her mom and then I but then in fifth
grade like we rented a slumber party and
watched it and I didn't sleep well
probably to this day after that I mean
that movie affected me very much so um
Evil Dead 2 was huge for me um Nightmare
on Elm Street the OG and I think the
thing the thing might be my favorite
horror movie oh yeah okay it's practical
effects all the Practical effects and
just the patience that it has the amount
of time that it takes and it's it's
lulling you into it it's it's
hypnotizing You Into The Narrative of
the movie and then when everything goes
wrong it's uh it's phenomenal and then
it's got maybe my favorite last scene of
a movie ever where like
not gonna spoil you know 30 30 movies
yeah but um but it's you know
one of these guys is probably infected
and you don't know who and you don't
know when
um is it over or is it not and I just I
love that to death and it's getting into
Peak Kurt Russell which is secret
Russell John Carpenter again you know
the master
um yeah but I was I was a big 80s horror
kid and sort of fell off in like the 90s
and the early 2000s I mean I used to
love staying up late with my sister
watching like USA up all night and stuff
like that where they would start running
horror movies and not necessarily good
ones but you would have horror movies
like The Killer baby from it's alive and
you like you're you're Christine's which
is which is a really cool premise for a
horror movie based on the Stephen King
and and then you also have the Exorcist
which by the way I don't know how much
y'all are aware of this because I had no
idea this was the thing that was
happening but when I was at cinemacon
they ran a little trailer for Exorcist I
can't remember the subtitle of it but
it's like a Blum House thing and holy
God
whoa it's gonna do things to me again
it's good I'm gonna need to borrow Molly
for those nights when I get home from
seeing the Exorcist because it is going
to scare the crap out of me Mark I'm
curious if you and I totally get falling
off in the 90s I don't know if we have
as many hits as the 80s did but did you
kind of come back with scream or were
you like nah you were past that I mean I
I watched the screams and like I know
what you mean I'm talking about the
first screams yes
I've seen the first two screams and then
it just got silly for me
um I think the last horror movie that I
saw in a theater was the ring yeah
um solid gray theater experience which
is yeah it was amazing and then then it
became like I it got torturous for me I
don't know yes
it became torture porn and it became
like I just didn't relish that feeling
it it got so manipulative like jump
scared jump scares I don't want the jump
scare like I want I want the existential
scare that's what like 80s and 90s hard
did for me because they didn't have a
lot of the tools it became here's the
you know implacable Unstoppable bad guy
here's a dude who can get into your
dreams like that became the thing that
just monkeyed with my head in ways that
I didn't need Gore and and jolts yeah to
get
um and then I think the last one that I
really kind of dug into was Cabin in the
Woods because it's it's both it
functions as horror but then it's
something else completely different
throws everything at you there's
everything I love that elevator opening
scene in Cabin in the Woods where it's
just everything you've ever been scared
of just yeah
I put the strangers up there too with a
movie like post 2000 that felt like one
of the classic Thrillers where it's just
this couple in this remote area and that
trailer sold it so well just a dude with
burlap on his head just peeking in and
then peeking back out oh my God that
movie's scary as hell yeah like funny
games like Michael hennik is funny yeah
but it's it becomes it's about like just
invading your space it's it's it's a
home invasion movie and the
unknowability of why people are doing
the things that they're doing like
that's the stuff that's so frightening
to me that I don't need you know the the
mirror closing and the bad guy but
that's not what horror does for me I do
think in the odds it did take this turn
which I equate to saw which I do think
saw was very smart and Innovative but
then there were so many copycats of it
that it was it did turn into this
torture porn that I just didn't excite
like I just couldn't stomach it and it
also wasn't the horror that I grew up
with and enjoyed yeah and like like the
Hostile movies yeah and stuff like green
room like I understand the apps I think
was also another like kind of torturous
and honestly Texas Chainsaw Massacre is
in there it is yeah I mean and I was
never a Texas chainsaw guy like I just
never needed it and uh and so I prefer
the more I think the more psychological
stuff that's why Freddy Krueger is so
cool because like there's no real
defense like the whole thing about
Freddy is that he preys on you when you
are defenseless you're literally asleep
and so you got to be very creative if
you want to get out of that mess and I'm
just wondering for you too is there a
way to still revive these properties
that make sense or do we just leave them
buried which is the hardest thing to do
in horror and in the movies themselves
because the bad guys always come back
but no I mean Halloween if nothing else
the most recent Trilogy was successful
and I think people have their opinions
on the individual films it seems like
you always run into somebody who who
likes one of them it might not be the
same one that you like but they like at
least one of these new movies but is
there room for another reboot of Friday
the 13th or another nightmare in Elm
Street or is it just really time to just
move on to something else I'm gonna tell
you yes because there will always be
they're going to keep rebooting these
episodes we'll have a scream eight or
whatever the screams look like they're
not running out of steam anything no no
but I do think horror is the one place
that you can actually break new IP
because I think people are always hungry
for horror I think it's one of the best
places for new filmmakers and newer
writers to really get in there we saw
that with it follows with the babadook
with like you know I think people are
just excited for
I think people will show up for horror
and I think you really can't go wrong uh
ma was another one with Paranormal
Activity and it would also you can make
these movies
have them be expensive to make right I
mean that's the Blum House model right
yeah we're gonna make it for three
million dollars Evan will make 15 in the
theater that's how horror always used to
work and that's how for the most part
Hollywood used to work was just here's
our here's our metric right right
um and horror will always pull an
audience or will always perform
um no matter what social time you're in
the horror of it is still there's
something to be scared of
um I think I I agree that like we're
never gonna get away from the IP of it
just because that's the world we live in
but I think like finding people who can
do like the Invisible Man I thought was
a really smart remake yeah in that it's
divorced almost entirely from what the
original was except for the name but
it's updated it's modernized it's it
makes you afraid of a thing that we
currently have now as opposed to a guy
I've taken this potion that's making me
invisible I'm going to do naughty things
while I'm invisible yeah um and with Lee
one now I think it was also a film that
you can make free of the pressure of
rebooting an entire universe like what
the Dark Universe was going to be where
you don't have to have this one movie
with Tom Cruise and a mummy be so super
beloved that you can launch an entire
franchise on it just make a cool
individual horror movie and see what
happens yeah I did want to say our
friend akayla Cooper wrote malignant
yeah Megan which I'm sure those are have
launched franchises uh just with how
well they did so I oh I do think horror
is is one of the few places that you can
you can break into and speaking of the
Halloween movies David Gordon green
doing those he is the director of The
Exorcist believer is what producer Brian
has updated me on so I think that comes
out this fall and again the the footage
that we saw at cinemacon I was watching
The Flash movie like later in the day
but I was still just thinking about the
I will take your word for it
scared the crap out of me I do want to I
want to make a very very hard pivot oh
my God this entire 180 or 90 degrees
however hard this fast and furious turn
is because a little wizard behind the
curtain we're taping this before but as
of the Airing of this producer Brian's
got married
you got married I'm told the ceremony
was lovely the Reverend was hit or miss
but everybody else was great and I'll be
performing it so uh I want to ask y'all
your best wedding scenes in movies
what's the best wedding
that you've seen in a film I will set
the bar and start the bidding at
Spaceballs great wedding because there's
kind of like the wedding that was
supposed to happen that doesn't then we
do get married at the end we do the
super super short version do you do you
okay you're married
um great great bit
uh I think that the the weddings that I
that I like the most in movies I think
is in Crazy Rich Asians like I kind of
love that wedding sequence I think with
like the water on the ground and the
lilies and the you know rich people
weddings are the best weddings and
that's slightly more of a wedding film
than Spaceballs a little bit a little
bit but also I think my favorite is
Princess Bride
um it gets into your head because I've
done a few of them now and when you say
because you say the word marriage a
couple times and luckily I didn't grow
up really with The Princess Bride for
whatever reason I've seen a couple times
I respect it I know there's it's got its
lesion of fans but it's hard to have
Manwich in your head and still say
marriage I guess it's good that it's
such a popular movie Danny so even if I
slipped and said marriage people would
think I'm making a joke like making a
reference but I wasn't I just it's just
in your head I would push you down the
altar
if you were mine you did what my priest
what is uh what what is your your
wedding movies there a dream wedding
sequence you saw
um you know the thing that just keeps
coming up is Wedding Crashers which I I
guess came out during the time that we
were like that transformed 2005 I think
yeah it was right around there so all of
those are like in this special little
area of my semi-u when you're like oh
this is what it'll be like to be a fully
placed adult Bradley Cooper being like a
POS that's a dick yeah and then he sort
of plays the same version of that
character in The Hangover but he's a
little more likable even though he's
still got that douchey quality to him
and then from there he just became one
of the biggest stars on the planet
rightfully so he's great right and then
I think he
internalized a lot of that for Rocket
that's basically Rocket Raccoon is a
piece of crap is that punk rich guy from
uh from from wedding I mean he's just
like a dick if rocket had collars
um but yeah Wedding Crashers was so much
fun and I actually found out in like
filming something else that
um the whole they had in their script
the thing about the I Every Time I Think
of eye drops I think of how he got
diarrhea but you can actually like
really harm someone doing that so don't
do that ever same with that Donna Dumber
oh yeah did they do that in Dumb and
Dumber he pours a lot for fast effective
release okay when Jeff Daniels has the
poop scene it's because Jim Carrey
poisoned it because he knew that he was
going out with yeah uh you know don't do
that someone could end up in the
hospital don't do anything you've ever
seen in the movie yes please especially
Dumb and Dumber yeah there's like
nothing you should actually try in Dumb
and Dumber no if your friend is allergic
to hot pepper or even somebody if
somebody kidnapped you and they're
working on pepper because do what you
will but they poison the guy and he ends
up dying because they also give him rat
poison instead of his pills I do have to
say I do sometimes pet Molly and say
pretty bird
[Music]
his head
our Pet's heads are falling off here at
Rotten Tomatoes well that's gonna do it
for this episode of after dark just
about but before we say good night uh I
want to get another update on everything
in Mark and Danny's world so Danny why
don't you step up to the plate first
here we know we got into static I think
it just premiered yes at well leave the
Latino Film Festival you look great on
the carpet thank you thank you out here
we also got into Essence fest so we'll
be there in New Orleans in New Orleans
for all of our New Orleans uh listeners
out there oh I might have to make that
trip once you have a bed yet oh man I
actually walked around by myself and ate
all like oysters at every bar like I
would go because my friends were busy
filming out there it's big production a
lot of like Productions are happening
somewhere as like most most people go to
like uh go to downtown New Orleans and
they like get a beer at each bar you
were getting an oyster yeah so that I
could sit and like get water yeah
um this was last year by the way so this
um but yeah I would like to go I would
get like half a dozen oysters so like
and then I would go and then I'd walk
around for another few hours and then I
would sit at a bar and I'd order their
oysters because I wanted to taste all
the different ones I gotta look at the
hotel there's a famous haunted hotel
that oh I stayed there I didn't realize
that it was a famous haunted hotel when
I was staying there this is after the
fact but I'll never forget I was in the
lobby and me and my friend Eliza we were
doing a stand-up show at a theater there
we get to the hotel get checked in walk
into the elevators huge portrait like an
old French portrait and the person in
the paint looked exactly like me exactly
there's only nine faces in the world it
looked exactly like me and it just kind
of freaked me out and it is now one of
the like reputed most haunted hotels so
I'll let you know which hotel it is
should you want to or want to not stay
there and be haunted by ancestors
did you stay in the room uh I don't I
stay in a very nice room and like that's
the one hotel where you actually don't
want to stay in the nicest room because
that's probably where all the like Rich
dead people are haunting it um but it
was uh it would not a lot of sleep was
had that night I'll say that yeah uh so
Mr Bernard you also have a short
Splinter about the piece of all spark
that Sam woodwicky had recovered yes not
about a rat who teaches Turtles how to
do kung fu
um uh yeah no I'm uh I'll be in
Chattanooga at the Chattanooga Film Fest
um
I will be at Comic-Con
um showing it off there on a panel with
hopefully some of my cast and members of
my crew and uh and yeah it's super
exciting it's fun that's so cool keep us
posted here at uh RT is wrong when you
know the exact date of when it's planned
so I can relay it to all the kids out
there because I want to go check it out
too I appreciate that thank you yeah
we'll be down there at Comic-Con Danny I
imagine you you're you're always uh
sought after uh panelist down there I'm
sure I'll I'll be there yeah I got it my
stand-up show is on Thursday of
Comic-Con at American Comedy Company 8
P.M
um and you can get tickets at mark
ellis.live my special should be dropping
a little earlier in July so I gotta
start writing some news gotta start
running some new materials that's right
I think last year it may happen this
year as well I do a live fat man beyond
with Kevin Smith and it always seems to
be counter programming with Mark Ellis
so not that you have to choose World wow
but you have to choose well I was just
gonna say make sure Splinter isn't
premiering at the time I stand up want
to go check that out it'll be during the
day yeah all right so once fat man
Beyond Live is sold out come on over to
the stand-up show I'm sure we'll both
sell out there's a lot of our a lot of
our people down there and I'm sure we'll
bump into each other at the parties and
all that good stuff so uh best of luck
and thank you all for uh all the great
work you're doing representing the wga
out there on the picket line when you're
driving by and SoCal you see all those
lovely Pickers out there give them a
honk give them your support
um it's uh it's uh you know certainly a
stressful time but it's impressive to
see how much fun the wga is making with
different theme days they had a singles
day singles day superhero day there's a
horror day at the Sony lot there's
there's sort of the Affinity groups
there's like Black Riders at Paramount
and Latino writers over here like it's
kind of all over and everywhere and it's
wonderful until it will stop it
until we all run out of gas keep putting
those Good Vibes out there in the world
that is Mark Bernardin and Danny
Fernandez for the whole crew here
including my incredible co-host
Jacqueline Coley I am merely Mark Allen
Go to rottentomatoes.com for all the
latest in the world of TV movies and
everything in between and do we know
what movie we're doing next week we do
not know it's a mystery so stay tuned
here from all of us to all of you at
Rotten Tomatoes as well
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]